a cover of Health magazine and it's the
first
unretouched cover in the magazine's
history hard because everything nowadays
is so filtered it's every touch was it
hard and scary especially six months
after having a baby it was so scary and
leading up I was still breastfeeding
when I did this shoe and I was just
freaking out the whole time my heart was
probably good because they're real full
I know but you know I'm retouched is
actually really hard for everybody on
set I noticed like you know the makeup
artist the hairstylist everyone's like
oh my god what we gonna do with her
bruise on her knee like who's gonna
cover it the makeups not covering it
everything's very stressful and doing it
in natural lighting adds that very real
element as well boy a natural lighting
is not my friend but I like a nice amber
dim light no but it was really important
for me to do this because you know we
were on Instagram all the time we see
people photoshopping everything you're
like when does it end and you know when
you're scrolling on Instagram you
constantly compare yourself to these
other people and for me I wanted us like
take a step back and show a real moment
of someone who actually is six months
postpartum is not being photoshopped and
be that real person and real influence I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this